please don't have children there should
be a swat team that just throws a bag
over her and takes her
i saw some of this pop up on my general
youtube and facebook and instagram feed
and i've seen some of these and every
time i see them everyone's like
and i don't think it's hahaha i think
it's disturbing and scary yeah
it's [ __ ] up and it shows the level of
our education system and our enemies are
watching this going oh yeah we got that
our enemies are like yeah we got these
mofos i actually got my gender studies
degree just i just graduated no no no no
nobody in this shit's got a degree
before we go any further make sure to
follow us on all of our social media
platforms sunny fast on all socials
sonny's mother on instagram and our
rumble youtube has been taking down some
of our videos so if you want to stay in
contact yeah that's horse and keep
watching
do you know how many stars there are on
the us flag oh my god 52
yes what state is utah in
michigan
yes you know what state utah is in
there's no way
utah
to be honest you have never heard of
that place ever in my life
i live under a rock can you name three
countries besides [ __ ]
[Music]
i suck at history i was like my worst
subject can we do like science
no no any three any three you know a
country
oh my
dimes the history i love three so she
doesn't even know that it's geography
that just is that was okay
it's like ten and nine those things i
don't care both of those questions are
great
question
grandma's television is so [ __ ] loud
from space you think she can hear us
over it no so she's got steve harvey
screaming up there
[ __ ] crazy all right what were you
saying you got the girl with the utah
and the other girl with the other two
countries because they don't even know
basic geography
as
clear graduates of the united states
education system
this can't be real this can't be real
okay it's real did they give all these
people ecstasy an hour before and
they're like whoa you know like they
don't know i don't know they must be on
some like they must be like no there
aren't extreme stupidity we used to be
the top all right can we keep because if
we yell over every time someone answers
something wrong we're never going to
finish the video i don't care so we need
you to just watch it it's only 11
minutes let's yell the whole time
[Music]
make up one dollar dimes come on a dive
is the ten set or the five set these
people work like the all right there's
no way she is like an entrepreneur she
doesn't run her own business she
probably works somewhere where you need
to know that kind of stuff how how do
you do business at all
i'm now i'm no i'm the one pausing no
i'm the one bring it down bring it down
business forget business how did she get
through did she not be a cashier how did
she graduate from the third grade to the
fourth grade i know [ __ ] business
overthinking it you're overthinking
i don't know
came in three countries besides the usa
there's no [ __ ] way
yeah
any three you know this
but she's got putting on fake lashes
down
right look at her
yeah she had way better lashes than me
uh
yeah
new mexico
[Music]
how many continents are there three
continents
yeah yes do you know what two countries
border the u.s
nah this is it
boarded yeah all like on the borders
yeah this isn't even the one the only
border i know is
puerto rico and mexico
yes who fought in the civil war
um i don't know
you talking about president
president-wise
no the people who against two
i don't know
she marched in a blm march because she's
at a gay pride thing she probably
marched into blm march about how hard
the black people have it and their
[ __ ] slaves and all that and she
doesn't even know who fought in the
[ __ ] civil war to free them i wonder
how long they had to interview people to
get these stupid questions this is why
somebody in the comments on one of the
more recent videos told us to comment on
this because they knew i was going to
lose my [ __ ] mind over um
france and the british are the same
thing right yeah yeah
damn i don't know
who did they fight against
us
yes do you know what continents we're on
right now
new york
do you know who fought in the civil war
um
who fought in civil war uh is this
staged can this many people be this
stupid like from the president
no like once again
it was so weird
the nazis oh yeah versus germany oh oh
yes thank god yeah she's [ __ ]
brilliant shoot myself i can't watch
this this is horrible sometimes on a day
where i have brain fog and i'm like i'm
not pumping out genius ideas and like my
scripts aren't coming out as good i'm
like maybe i am [ __ ] and then i
watch this and i'm like all right maybe
i'm not maybe i'm not so bad this is the
education system this is the education
is this the education system or is this
just people are like there's just
there's a spectrum of people mom like
some people are gonna be the basic
[ __ ] knowledge seven continents
like this is you had to learn seven
continents who fought in the civil war
north and south yes it's a civil [ __ ]
world you actually just guessed that nah
yeah i'm kind of you didn't know that
i'm good
kardashian sisters can you name
kendall jenner kylie jenner kim
kardashian um khloe kardashian i'm proud
to say that i don't i don't even know i
kind of name them the only one i can
even pick out of the lineup is kim
that's it yeah because she did kanye you
know i don't know who the rest of them
are
um courtney cardas who cares
who cares why is this like why on like
when you go to a grocery store and the
last thing you see is these [ __ ]
magazines where it's like the
kardashians like who buys that stuff
it's these people they're droids mom we
live in a like i'm not even i'm not even
exaggerating we live in a society where
there are literal droids like this isn't
a real person back it back there's no
way we do education system because we
didn't act like this 30 years ago droids
didn't act like this 30 years ago from
birth this is what they're taught is
important who the modern kardashians are
who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't even know
who fought
how many seasons are there oh this is
bad
okay so this this just to be fair we're
never going to get it
a stephen hawking type of genius beyond
genius yeah try to have a conversation
with me about science you'd be like this
guy i would look like this guy right but
those are the exceptions they're like
the the sliver creme de la creme of
humanity he looks at them how annoying
life must be for those so now now look
now think about it like this the elites
and the people that are controlling the
world are like extreme intelligence
because if you need to do that you need
to be the elite of the elite and the
smartest people so think about how they
look at these people they're like oh
yeah we'll do literally whatever we have
to do to control them even with the
stuff that they even us they think that
we're just a bunch of
they look at you whoever's out there
watching like a number and us no not
even like a number they think we're
drooling idiots we're about as
intelligent as a dog or a hedgehog or a
cat ruling idiots because you had a
woman here 10 seconds ago who couldn't
name the who couldn't name who fought in
the civil war but could name all the
kardashians of course the
hyper-intelligent humans are gonna go uh
yeah we got this let's [ __ ] move
these pawns around learn yeah
three countries besides your [ __ ]
mind
no come on this guy looks like
this guy looks smart yeah he's got to
get it
come on g you sound articulate
come on bro no yes
it is utah utah i don't know what you
thought
is this like a new yorker thing that
they don't know where utah is
i don't know
i don't know history like you don't know
history it's nothing to do they must be
this must be staged this must be staged
because they're both saying history now
no this is the same chapter the same
broad as before three times three times
three is
three times three times three
three
you know this yeah i know this wow this
doesn't even include pemdas this doesn't
even include pemdas what's pemdas it's
the order in which you do math words
so if it's like math if it's like
multiplication division nine times three
is twenty-seven i i'm sorry that's where
i know but i'm saying like that doesn't
even include like because sometimes it
gets a little bit trickier if you forget
pemdas and how it works people [ __ ]
you the points of things you go around
in third grade sometimes you forget like
which which would you do like long
division is it's hard for me now because
it's been a lot of years yeah i i do
long division i don't need to know how
to do long division i have a [ __ ]
calculator
when i'm making my stacks i'm not doing
long division
my bugatti i don't i don't have to do it
long division that's supposed to be a
trick that's supposed to be a trick
thing but like a trick question
no it's not that's what i'm that's what
i just said actually i just said it's
not even like a trick question it's
literally straight up
this is we're never gonna finish this
video what's three times three times
three no dude three times three times
three
all right
see he looks like he know he should know
the answer he doesn't look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yet he's been graduated
without from the third grade without
knowing that
um
36
yes
how did you get 36 i'm nine times three
times three
twenty twenty three nine nine
i don't know
at least he got to nine number nine
thirty six
he got to nine he got three times
where are they getting 36 from i don't
get it where's the the last guy just
said 36 too like i'm i'm genuinely
curious about what process went through
their mind no process did you did you
not did you guys not learn this trick
where you just put your [ __ ] finger
down and you can look at your hand yeah
yeah 27 did nobody else learn that no we
didn't listen
we just learned how to think if you're
doing 9 times anything if you're doing 9
times anything you just put put that so
9 times 3 you put that finger down it's
27 same [ __ ] works i'm so stupid i'm
just saying wow maybe i'm i grew up in a
weird school way in it you did
what's three times three times three
i do that every time now i also know how
to do really great islands right now
no those aren't attractive with those
long islands no they're currently i
suppose none of that i don't know what
consonant i'm not i don't know his name
but i don't know
i heard it i know you remember his name
i know he's from bulldog i'm not
mistaken what's the capital of chicago
um
capital of chicago
i gotta think
yeah this is a tough one
the capital of chicago
is it los angeles i feel like that's so
wrong wow yeah
yeah so right
um
capital of chicago i really don't know
that one what language do the people in
idaho speak
what like the language the people who
live in idaho what do they speak i did
an interview question like this where i
asked does a woman's body count matter
well that was more of like an
intellectual conversation should i go to
new york and just like we're like a half
hour away right now should i go and ask
[ __ ] like this for a video that would be
kind of cool no don't do it
this is a [ __ ] waste of time these
people are [ __ ] lost bottom feeders
[ __ ] hell no
i don't know what
japan do you know how many prizes we've
had so far
oh no
no like around how many
this is my favorite when the [ __ ]
democrats are like we're gonna invest in
education education this is the result
of their [ __ ]
this really is just the bottom one
percent to be honest not totally sure no
this is the reason i agree democrat
policies on united states american
education can you move in [ __ ]
i'm here i'm in the camera let me know
just leave me excuse me
yes around there how long is a quarter
of an hour 25 minutes
yes
you said what two countries what porter
[Music]
mexico i don't [ __ ] know mexico and
um come on come on you're so close
you're so good
yes
how many times make up one dollar how
many dimes yeah oh my god we're doing
math now the questions i can't answer
would you ask for science what [ __ ]
science questions are you gonna answer
i'm genuinely curious about what science
question questions she would have gone
keep going because i'm gonna lose my
[ __ ] minds on this i'm sorry
um
dimes dimes you dumb and this is
somebody who thinks she's got it all
over everybody else because she's
wearing a prize how many minutes are in
half an hour 60.
yes
yes 60 right in half an hour no forty
five thirty
thirty twenty forty five
which number one number four
[Music]
thirty five
yeah yes
messed up
how many times make up one dollar
nah this isn't real oh we had that
billboard thousand or 100
a hundred
yes what year was the u.s founded
what year yeah oh you lost me with that
one
around what year you know this around
what year was founded
there should be sad music playing
i feel like i should know this one i
feel like you do know this one
what year was it this is like the one
question where i'd be like all right if
you at least guess the 1700s i'd be like
all right at least you're there like at
least you're close by you know what i
mean right like give them a little slack
on this one this is the one where it
gives someone a little slack but the two
countries that border the us come on
what do you think under over 1850 under
over under no way nah you got it with
that one over i guess like around one
year if you have to guess
yes
a year around one found it i'm gonna be
like um
1962 1995 no 94.95 95. okay so when this
happens
there should be a swat team that just
[ __ ] throws a bag over her and takes
her takes her out and takes it back to
the first [ __ ] grave big bag over
your head
first grade and takes you into a little
[ __ ] secret place sometimes a quarter
of an hour is infuriating
these are the people we're walking
around the streets with yes how many
seasons are there
oh come on
wait
spring right yeah stuff seasons spring
summer
yeah four
spring summer waterfalls you got it if
you're driving 60 miles an hour and
you've been driving for one hour then
how far do you travel
i jumped out like oh
yeah
and you've been driving for an hour then
what's the distance you go how far do
you travel
[Music]
i don't drive i'm gonna cry myself to
sleep tonight scratch my head i don't
know
i wish i knew but i don't know take a
guess like imagine you're in a car
and you're driving 60 miles an hour and
then you've got 60 miles
yeah it is pretty fast so how far do you
think you would get in that time
it wouldn't take me that way like if i
was thinking of questions to ask i'd say
like in an hour and a half because then
you'd have to multiply by 1.5 but the
point of this is he's asking like most
basic questions
i'm sorry and they still 20 minutes
yes yes do you know how many stars there
are in the u.s flag
he asked how far you go and she said 20
minutes
okay
around how many
[Music]
15 16
have you ever looked at a [ __ ] flag
oh my god yes how long is a quarter of
an hour
like 30
half an hour that's 30 minutes right
yes when do they celebrate the fourth of
july in england
i don't know
i don't know
if you had to guess
is it in july 2 oh this is sad
yes this is like a funeral
do you know who following the civil
war you know who fought in the civil war
people
yeah
you got me there if you were born 10
years ago then how old would you be
today
10 years ago
i don't i'll be like 14 12
12.
you don't even know how old i am
if i was what was it again if you were
born 10 years ago today four and 10
years ago today how old would i be
i'm 20.
you're 20.
please don't have children 10 right i
said 12 close
yes
people are graduating from high school
without even knowing what that three
times three is nine yeah it's crazy uh
let me know if you guys actually want us
to make an entire video reacting to ben
shapiro's most savage moments i feel
like that would be savage moments of ben
shapiro i don't care if you want it or
not we're doing it you gotta see it it's
awesome before we cut it off make sure
to join the discord follow some other
social medias and that's all i gotta say
smile later
[Music]
won't last long